public speaking the number one fear for
people right before number two
death in this episode i want to help an
extreme introvert become confident and
eventually do public speaking
meet my girlfriend tegan why do you want
to overcome your shyness it just sucks
the enjoyment
out of everything so i made a list of
challenges that would slowly build up
her confidence the first task
asking a stranger for directions okay
you can do this
but it was much harder for her than i
anticipated and she was only comfortable
if i walked up with her
excuse me thank you very much yes we did
it
same with the other challenges i had
planned do you think you want to go into
the store and buy something and then do
a little bit of small talk
with the cashier
i realized this was going to be far more
challenging than i thought
if i don't change there's just more of
the same not living up to the person i
know i can be
how could we possibly get a confident
enough to deliver a speech in front of
an audience you might be introverted
but nobody's born to be this anxious so
i thought there must have been something
in the past that made her this way so
one thing your dad told me about you is
that
you were always obsessed with following
the rules
where do you think that comes from the
first thing that pops up the
fear of like getting yelled at for doing
something
bad wrong was there a time when that
happened when i was about
four years old i started to cross the
street without looking
and my dad pulled me back and was like
what are you doing like you have to look
both ways hey
stop obviously he was doing his job to
protect me but i got really scared
did you change your behavior from then
on yeah i would be more careful with
what i say
more careful with my actions like could
this hurt somebody
and she's still doing it to this day i
think before
everything it's really exhausting how
could you not be socially anxious when
you overthink
everything here's where it gets a bit
weird all of us have
multiple identities inside of us for
example you might have one that's always
worried an ambitious achiever a
conscientious one the goofy part of you
and even if you don't admit it
maybe a little can and all of them serve
a different purpose
ever notice how you behave very
differently when you speak to your
great-grandparents than if you were
hanging out with a close friend or
maybe a special someone that's because
different parts of you take over
and when tegan turned from a playful
adventurous girl to one that's obsessed
with following the rules it's because
she created a new identity
that took over most of the time that
would prevent her from going through the
same pain again
why don't we give her a name like an old
lady's name like a janet
and what is your purpose janet keeping
taken safe
you know like when the mother just like
wants to like protect their kids so much
that they don't let them like
grow and try new things but janet is
just
one part of her you've taught me about
another part of you as well
when you went traveling and you wanted
to surf i was dragged underwater like
seven times i was about to quit and so i
said okay
one more day then i just had an amazing
surf session where i was able to paddle
out
catch waves it was exhilarating because
i stuck with it
now was that janet who decided to not be
a quitter and stick to it no
who was that that was serena blaze
serena
is the counterpart of janet i started
crafting her in my mind when i was
probably like seven
all of us have a serena inside of us if
we went with serena approached ms
strangers
how would she do she'd be fine okay then
let's go out in public again and
see how you do we need a process to
activate serena
and after using some simple techniques
to switch between identities
we were ready to tackle a list of 10
challenges that would get her out of her
comfort zone
starting with the easier ones pick a
song that gets you going you roll down
the window
[Music]
[Applause]
go towards the exit where it clearly
says exit only and you go towards it
until someone stops you
oh she's going and now
i have a little small talk with the
cashier great job i was freaking out
ask for directions this time do it with
less hesitation excuse me is barton
springs this night
nice you did it good job yeah
when serena was in charge things that
seemed terrifying before were now
almost fun imagine you could activate
that strong part of you at any time
but how did we switch between identities
who we embody
is like an automatic cycle between our
feelings behaviors
and thoughts you may feel afraid like
when janet is active in taken
which causes you to behave that way in
your body and with your actions
your shoulders fall forward you look
down you have a word look on your face
twiddling nervously your voice changes
as well which then causes you to
think fearful thoughts like her just
imagining the worst possible scenarios
which then again reinforce the feelings
and so on but we need to interrupt it
by consciously embodying the strong part
of you and we start with our behavior
because it's the easiest to control how
would your inner hero behave
which starts with our posture how we
breathe the look on our face
which quickly changes your biochemistry
shoulders back chest out
breathing more deeply a confident smile
yes
that's it and even things like the
clothes you wear they reminded me of
like some confident women i've met in my
life who
wore bangles like these then it's much
easier to change our thoughts
how would they think what would they say
to themselves what's a mantra
that you can repeat to yourself probably
let's do this what does she say
let's do this and we can start feeling
better very quickly until our inner hero
is fully in charge
and with that we went out to face the
really challenging stuff i want you to
lie down on the floor here where there's
people walking by
like a starfish arms out legs out i'm
gonna get yelled at
[Laughter]
do you know what she's what she's doing
there time is over
that was great at this point we just
went full
degenerate what if you go down this
bridge and as you're walking
you're making animal noises let's do
this
you did it let's keep going all right
but let's funny
wait you i'm stressing you now
this is pretty uncomfortable i felt
uncomfortable how do you feel now
more light yeah more expressive more
free
yeah imagine you could be like this all
the time that would be
relieving until it was time for the most
uncomfortable interaction
ask someone for directions when they
tell you the directions you go the
opposite way
are you ready though janet had come out
again she felt scared and then started
behaving that way by looking down
shallow breathing imagining all the
things that could go wrong but the
strong part of you is always there
it just needs to be activated act as
serena like how would she act
shoulders back standing strong deep
breath and this is the most challenging
part
interrupting the cycle and activating
that inner hero when you're feeling down
it goes against our instinct to behave
different to how we feel it's not to
get rid of the fear avoid the fear it's
do it scared but the more you interrupt
the cycle the easier it gets
until it's almost automatic i'm doing it
what does serena say let's do this
yes all right she goes excuse me it's
whole foods this way
you did phenomenal i did a good job yeah
naturally
the next stage from here would be that
maybe
you could go in front of an audience and
present a three to five minute speech
a week earlier we had already checked
out at toastmasters meeting of the zoo
which is an organization where people
practice public speaking and they
invited us to participate for the table
topics exercise where you asked a
question to which you have to improvise
a two-minute answer
no what if tomorrow we join for the
toastmasters again and you join for the
table topics
no do not take the comfort pillow you
come out of your comfort zone right now
demand an appointment with serena
shoulders back
chest out deep breath what do you think
serena
there's the inner battle between janet
and serena who's gonna win
you can bring out serena anytime you
need her so you think you can do this
let's do this i don't think you're gonna
back out of this
why not next tuesday guess who showed up
again
my head hurts my back hurts i'm tired
but after a usual process we practice so
many times by now
to bring out serena give me one more
breath
she was almost like a different person
again good on you for doing this
you feel ready we just had to make sure
that she continues being serena because
if janna took over now
that would be a pretty bad experience i
feel like my mind would blank
next time it might be you posture up
nice you got this
and then it was her turn the question
was
what is a fictional character that you
would like to meet
um first off i'll just say thank you
everyone for having me here
and
[Music]
i would say a tv character actually her
name was
kim possible she was on a disney tv show
and when i was growing up i was very shy
she really just symbolized the kind of
person that i wanted to be when i grew
up
fighting for humanity and like
protecting her loved ones so i would
like to
kind of just say thank you for being a
good role model thank you for your time
everyone
you did it you did it yeah isn't it
weird how you like it
and you did it once again i was hoping i
would do better
but no stop no don't beat yourself up
don't want to hear any focus on the
negative
let's do this you do really well so the
next logical step would be to
volunteer for a five-minute speech at
toastmasters
what are you afraid of what are your
main concerns i'm afraid of
my mind going blank and not being able
to continue with the speech
and i might cry while i'm still on the
call
as long as serena is in charge you're
good if janet comes out
it's gonna be a real problem and this
time it was a real concern
it seemed like her fearful part janet
was bringing everything she had to the
final battle and she brought out
all these horror scenarios for taking to
stop her from moving forward what if i
try it
and then i forget like what i'm supposed
to say and i look down at my notes
and then i'm just like freezing and just
staring okay what are the chances of you
panicking
well it's happened every single time
that i've had it
what do you think they're gonna think
she sucks she's
socially inept i had to find a way to
get her out of that funk
this was the final challenge and if she
stopped here i knew it would have been
all for nothing
because she would have felt so beaten
down despite all of the progress she
made
but i saw a possibility all of these
mind tricks that janet brought out to
keep taken anxious and safe from danger
are really common
for people who struggle with any form of
anxiety and these tricks are called
cognitive distortions cognitive
distortions are a list of 10
types of thoughts that the psychiatrist
david d
burns outlined in his best-selling book
feeling good people that struggle with
social anxiety and being really shy
they have certain mental distortions
that if you think these thoughts
you're guaranteed to feel anxious but
the good thing about these thoughts is
they're just twisted thoughts
they're just not true and she was doing
almost all of them by the book
for example when she said she should
have done better and focus on the
negative instead of on what she did well
fortune telling the future by imagining
the worst possible scenarios
already mind reading and assuming what
people are gonna say about her without
any
evidence whatsoever or over-generalizing
by saying she's going to panic because
it happened in the past once
if you do any of these you will feel
anxious or depressed
it's almost like simple math and after
challenging her on each of them by
showing her that they were just not
based
in reality janet's tricks weren't
working that well anymore and we were
able to bring back serena how would
serena deliver the speech
like a boss like crying wouldn't be
variable it's not like a possibility and
i was able to convince her to lock in
her five-minute speech
i accept this challenge and with that
it was time to prepare the speech was
going to be in a few days and of course
her fears were still there so she
finished writing her speech
we practice how to visualize delivering
the speech well to prepare her mind
we even simulated the entire setup with
a fake zoom call i created
and after all we had been through she
was about to face the most
terrifying challenge a shy introvert
could imagine
it's time tegan's ready to give a speech
script ready
shoulders back test out i'm getting
nervous now too
all right let's join the call tayden
will be speaking tonight from
presentation mastery this is her
icebreaker join me in welcoming
tayden conley hi thank you everyone
appreciate it um alrighty
and then she
absolutely crushed it looking at where
she started
and now after a few weeks seeing her do
public speaking like this
thank you everyone for your ears in your
mind
oh you did so well it makes you wonder
yeah what are we truly capable of
if we gave ourselves a chance
[Music]